Lauren bobbert is a disgrace to this
country not because the V you are 100%
right forget the politics she's in a
dress if you saw the video she's in a t
dress she's with some dude I I've seen
stars wear more his politics are all
completely just standard leftist
backwards whatever Howard CERN did once
interview Harvey Weinstein before the
whole thing blew up and uh take a listen
to this why I stay single I got to
figure every Starlet in Hollywood want
to at least blow you doesn't work that
way every girl knows that that that if
she's a competent actress if she could
get on your good side you could make her
a star over night look I I don't care
about people doing drugs privately I
don't care about people getting jobs
everyone I know is gotten a from Julia
Roberts I mean come on the point is that
he's on one hand these are the cultural
taste makers and when you're a leftist
you can do and say anything and you're
protected and when you're not they'll
destroy you